part H and following are all about this
phrase consider the bill for the same
period last year the bill that you do
not have however we have enough
information trying to work out what
happened in that field okay it says what
was the average daily usage so which
part of the bill they trying out so
again don't go to a gas
I'd suggest this code is here right we
already noticed that this part tells us
about what happened this time but we're
interested in the safety of last year so
which other column is that which one
it's the one on the right isn't it okay
so I'm just going to do that
it is something videos riderhood user
training to be able to point to the left
and say to the right you know how hard
that is
anyway okay good not really good I went
yeah whatever right which one okay for
you somebody Irene is in I'll beckon it
yeah let me get your boss my hurry
Irene could you get the bill please
please that's okay I'm just reading
today okay stay with me as well okay now
we've already identified the part of the
Builder is important but we need all the
information that we there's relevant
there not only do we want the average
daily usage which you can read a 13
kilowatt hours they also asked for the
total amount of electricity used for
this period which is not hence this is
one of those where is the number of the
bill the number is not on the bill you
have to get it from the bill what do you
do
so have you done this how did you
calculate the total amount of power that
you everybody they can assure look right
there if you look carefully it tells you
how many days that period was whatever
why is it to differ the number of days
summer 31 413 number 28 which in fact is
what accounts for the fact that I'm
actually is it the next one I asked you
if the next one is going to be a short
one can you see why the next bill will
be ashore it will include the next bill
will include February 28 ad it won't
include 29 or 30 or 31 so you're gonna
have a short one
alright just clean back we've got the
average daily usage 30 kilowatt hours
we've calculated the total amount of
electricity used
can I please encourage you not to change
your Wi-Fi settings but to say what you
are calculating I've beaten this trouble
before I would beat it again okay what
you should have in your book is not just
a number but average daily use right
right 13 fewer what hours please include
the unit you need to really avoid you
then when you say total usage I'm going
to encourage you not just to write down
to 13 times 95 right one of them is an
electricity quantity and the other one
is a period of time so I'm going to
write 13 kilowatt hours times 95 I can
tell which one is which pretty sure
that's 1235 because I already calculated
yeah I could it's not that hard it's not
that hard 13 times ie 5 30 times 95 is
close to 30 times 100 right so it's like
1,300 - a little bit
okay stay with me have a look what's the
next question what they ask next part I
total electricity usage is broken down
in the same proportion then what was
used in peak shoulder and off peak okay
now it says in the same proportion where
do I get those proportions from where
are the proportions
look Stan jeez you see breakdown right
so see these numbers in here right
thirty four point ninety one percent
fifty point five for fourteen point five
for I'm going to have to multiply each
of those numbers by what one thousand
two hundred thirty five thirty four
point ninety one percent of that one
thousand to thirty five that'll be the
peak usage and then the shoulder it is
the object okay so how I'm going to do
that let me actually show you how we
would write that I would say last year
that's my I should I should make that
we're heading I'm going to say peak it's
going to be what's the percentage in
thirty four point thirty four point nine
one percent thank you times that total
1235 kilo watt hours that's going to
give me a number this number I don't
have if someone got it yeah I also don't
forget the units okay I'm going to do it
for shoulder I'm going to do it for
off-peak and then we'll give me some
different quantities okay
I won't repeat it just the same process
with different numbers what I will do is
show you what to do with that number
that was entering here is part H up here
this is part I you can complete that for
shoulder and for off it so this is I and
this is one that's not computer at all
is that there were many rules so part I
Part 1
that's not then in part J it is using
your answer to Part I
that's not a physics calculate the
energy usage for the pewter okay here's
what you got to do great you're going to
get your numbers for last year's pink
there it is last year's shoulder last
year's off pig in fact some of you
already worked that out can you actually
tell me what the number is so what's the
shoulder I'll just I'll just go with you
hey that's my cue
can someone else you baby I'll be six
that's right okay so now I know what's
been used in each of the zones so to
work out the cost I use the same rate so
in fact what the question says use the
same rates as on this bill which are
double look here they are do you guys
yeah those ones right there okay so
thankful enough little bit let me see if
I can do because I'm not a [ __ ] work
I'm just going to write my calculations
down here so part J the usage cost by
the way what else is the clot a part of
usage there's another computer robot
because just the energy availability
that's service price which doesn't
depend on how much energy you use what
is it depend on just having electricity
for however number of how it'll be
number of days that you had electricity
which in this case is for this bill 95
so I'll get that or those 93 in the
current bill but I'm thinking about
watches bill oh yeah okay so I'm gonna
say alright 431 point 1 kilowatt hours
multiplied by what does this cost on
this is how many total kill or ally in
that forty seven point seven seven
right I'm just finding everything now
what I'll point out is please notice my
unit I know it gets a bit tiresome but
you will get really good at if you do
this the cost is in cents per
kilowatt-hour is it that said take you
on our so look at what happens to the
units kilowatt hours per kilowatt hours
so they cancel just like any normal
faction right so now you're going to get
a number calculator okay is not
unreasonable to turn it into new dollars
so if you did that that's fine for 31.1
times you can do them all in one hit
that's fine so I have two zero five nine
three point six four seven one of my
units I haven't done any conversion
that's sense right yeah so now I'm going
to write dollars on the next line nine
and that again if you went straight to
this line that's cool just tell me that
you're doing that please do not just
write two hundred and five point nine
for what units are you talking about it
makes a really big deal what users are
talking about so that's why you can see
even though it gets a little longer the
truth writing user every time make sure
it makes me certain that I'm getting
right so easy